hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
so 30th Amash you're watching games but
news Mortal Kombat producer Sean Hamrick
has left Twitter as a result of violent
tweets threatening both him and his
family the move came after him Erick
received tweets which threatened to
assault his family if he didn't include
a previous Mortal Kombat character in
the new game Hemric explained that he
understands fans might want to ask him
to include characters or ask for him but
he draws the line at individual to
threaten his wife and young daughter he
writes you want to fight me for any
reason I'm probably willing to go
verbally physically I can hold my own
but threats on my ladies no Twitter CEO
admitted earlier this year that the
company quotes suck at handling abuse
star citizen developer cloud imperium
games are now selling a new ship for the
game that will run new 250 bucks the
pricey craft called the A through G then
God actually isn't flight ready just yet
and is being sold through a concept sale
that ends april six it's got all the
bells and whistles though including for
forward-mounted high-caliber laser
cannons a central gattling gun and one
can hope at least a CD player since it's
the price of a small couch its price
will go up after this limited sale
period so if you want to front the cash
for it 250 bucks will buy you the ship
lifetime insurance and some decorative
items for your hangar of course this
isn't the most expensive ship star
citizen has ever offered just last
December the limited to 200 javelin ship
went on sale for 2,500 bucks apiece the
sale of virtual space ships like these
have helped staff citizen recently
crossed the crowdfunding milestone of 77
million dollars halo 5 guardians is back
in our sites today with the reveal of
two new trailers and a release date the
two trailers feature master chief and a
newbie Spartan Locke respectively and
according to xbox they represent two
sides of the same story last week micro
soft launched a hunt for the truth
teaser website for halo 5 which posed
the question who is the real master
chief it's been confirmed that master
chief and agent Locke will be playable
in the upcoming game and Cortana is
expected to make an appearance developer
343 industries boss Bonnie Ross herself
halo 5 will make gamers question all
they know about the Halo universe she
also promised the game will deliver
quote scope and scale and drama the
game's release is slated for october 27
of this year for xbox one let me know
down in the comments if you're rooting
for master chief or agent Locke you can
head to gamespot or we've got news on
playstation 4 launching its Spotify app
and a former Bungie dev heading for
bethesda those are all the good things
that I wanted to tell you about today as
always let me know what you cared about
and i'll catch you same time tomorrow